single ladies single ladies say ladies
that put dessert so hey it's and I'm
still single the good news is I'm still
happy to help all you other single
people out there to cook awesome recipes
for one Amen I will ask how to cook if
you're single video I covered breakfast
lunch and dinner
but there's one meal we didn't hit and
it might be the most important one of
all dessert so today I'm going to show
you three awesome desserts that are easy
to make and perfect for one it's gonna
be pretty sweet so to kick things off
we're going to be making a blueberry
cobbler for one its fruity refreshing
perfect for summer I think you'll be
surprised by just how easy it is to
treat yourself to something nice so to
my blueberries I'm adding a tablespoon
of sugar 2 teaspoons of flour gonna give
this a little mix you don't matter boo
but your blueberry cobbler will be your
boo berry cobbler and then I'm just
gonna pop the blueberries right into a
greased ramekin a ramekin is a great
vessel to have if you're single you can
bake with it and it's the perfect like
single serving size I'm gonna set my
blueberries aside and now in a medium
bowl I'm adding 1/4 of a cup of flour a
tablespoon of sugar 1/4 of teaspoon of
baking powder a pinch of salt and now
I'm gonna give this a little bit of mix
adding in two tablespoons of cubed cold
butter now I'm just gonna use my fork to
kind of cut this butter into our flour
mixture I'm just pressing the fork down
on those cubes of butter and kind of
cutting them into the flour mixture it
will look kind of like crumbly like pea
sized pieces the texture of this will
allow for a late here cobbler crust once
we bake it all right our mixture is
looking good
time to add the milk so 2 tablespoons of
milk right in there and now I'm just
gonna give this one last mix so it will
come together more as like a dough all
right so now I'm just gonna pop our
little dough right onto our blueberries
so now I'm gonna pop this in the oven at
350 degrees Fahrenheit for about
thirty to thirty five minutes or until
the berries are bubbly and the top is
nice and golden brown all right here it
looks great it smells great the crust is
nice and golden brown the blueberries
are all juicy and the best part is
there's no need to plate it because you
can eat it straight from the dish oh
that looks so good
already oh my gosh that's a big bite mmm
just the right amount of sweetness it's
refreshing with the berries
restaurant-quality trade yo south am i
right the next dessert is one I'm
particularly excited for and I actually
lie to you guys I'm not saying because
bananas are my back as many of you guys
know I'm a little bananas for bananas so
today we're gonna be making a banana
s'mores boat this recipe is even easier
than the cobbler it's perfect if your
binge-watching a show you got sweet
tooth you need to whip something
together real fast these s'mores are
bananas be a ma and they yes so first up
I am going to crush up some graham
crackers I have these in a ziplock bag
you don't want to crush them up too much
they should still be a little coarse
this is also the perfect opportunity to
take out your aggressions again why am i
so sweet know why so now we're gonna get
a little funky what I'm gonna do is keep
the banana in its peel but cut it in
half very carefully so now I have a
baking sheet lined with foil I'm gonna
spray this down with some cooking spray
and I'm gonna place my prepared bananas
right on this I'm just gonna take a fork
and create a little bit of a crevice in
the center just kind of mash the banana
up so that it turns into like a little
banana boat right on top of there I'm
adding some chocolate chips right into
the center of our banana boat I know
we're making desserts for single people
right now but this is also a pretty good
dessert for a kid but I'm kind of like a
kid so works for me too now I'm gonna
top those with some mini marshmallows
just stick them right on this is not all
the elements of
traditional campfire smores it's just
the foot twist with the banana I'm just
gonna top that with some of our graham
cracker crumbs make sure they get all
under the banana so now I'm gonna pop
this in the oven at 350 degrees
Fahrenheit for about five minutes and
then we're gonna turn the oven to broil
for about one to two minutes or until
the marshmallows are toasty and breath
all right our bananas are roasted the
marshmallows are nice and toasty the
chocolate is melted looking perfect now
I'm just gonna pop the bananas on a
plate gotta get a little fancy with the
plating for your dessert for one right
and finally I'm just gonna drizzle our
bananas with a little melted chocolate
can never have too much chocolate well
that was super quick super easy the
perfect dessert for the average single
person or the average banana whoo well I
can't wait to try this one I'm gonna go
for it
how's my banana day
laughter today is for all you single
party people margarita popsicles
they're perfect for a hot day they're
refreshing they're easy but if you can't
drink don't worry I've got you covered
too often I'm going to show you a known
alcoholic person that's just as good
banana one thank you
so to a liquid measuring cup I'm adding
1/4 cup of white tequila
next is 1/2 a cup of lime juice I have
just the bottle once you don't have to
squeeze a lot of and a 1/2 cup of orange
juice plus I'm hiding 3 tablespoons of
honey you could also use something like
agave syrup here I'm just gonna whisk
not up so now I'm going to pour our
mixture straight into 6 shot glasses
fill em Araya
hopefully you have shot glasses on hand
I do before I pop them in the freezer
I'm just going to cover each shot glass
a little bit of aluminum foil I'm just
gonna pop a popsicle stick right through
the aluminum foil the foil will just
help keep that popsicle stick right up
in place pop these in the freezer for at
least 6 hours preferably overnight see
now it's a worry about it and so they
hold their shape and then we'll be ready
to party so while those are doing their
thing let's get into the non-alcoholic
version these are still super easy super
delicious and still waiting for a party
so to start I'm gonna add 1/2 a cup of a
lime juice 1/2 a cup of orange juice for
the cup of sweetened condensed milk this
is what's gonna give us so that extra
sweetness it'll also be really nice
because I'll give it a creamsicle flavor
I'm just gonna whisk this up team deal
we're gonna fill up our shop boxes the
shot glasses are still great for making
popsicle if you don't have a shot
glasses you can always use like paper
cups or something like that
again we're gonna
these with some soil when it freezes you
got a nice popsicle the pop these in the
freezer as well again six hours at least
preferably overnight to make sure
they're frozen solid and then it's party
time all right we've got our popsicles
already and right in front of us the
best part is you can keep them in the
freezer happen whenever you want it's a
hot day party day sad day
pop school make everything better all
right let's give it a try whoo
it's a popsicle and a bomber all in one
I might never got a shot at love but at
least I got a shot my popsicle what are
you having it three awesome desserts to
make if you're single let me know which
one these are favorite and the comments
below if you make any of them be sure to
tag me I'd love to see your creations
listen there is no shame in being single
you deserve to have your cake and eat it
too
all right factor for me again I'm gonna
swipe right on out of here that's left
so I play oh yes
[Music]
[Music]